لما توقف لم تحتاج لم
اوقف ولم احجز ابدا تطيله الفتره الماضيه
طيله الفتره الماضيه ان لم يكن هناك
استدعاءات في قضايا معينه
التحدث عن كل شيء موجود امام القضاء
همم
وبالمناسبه انا اللي ثقه في القضاء
التونسي رغم انه هنالك بعض ولي ثقه في
المحامين اللي هم يمثلوا يعني بالمسجد قوه
من من القوه التي تحمي همم
قضايا كانت في الصلب مطالبات الثوار يفصلت
وانتهت اخذت فيها براءه
تاخذ براءه من محكمه التعقيب في موضوع
فاذا به يطرح في العداله الانتقاليه قلت
لاتحدث عن هذا لان امام القناه لان هناك
اشكاليات ولكن لنا ثقه في تونس وفي
قضاياها هل مريسه هل طبقت العداله
الانتقاليه فعلا ام عدا الانتقائيه
الانتقاليه
اسلاميه
في الكثير من الحقد وفيها الكثير من
الشماته لان لم يكن في السلطه خلال 10
سنوات رغم انتقادي لهم ولكن عندما تكون
عندك سلطه وتكون هنالك النفس الكبيره
كان ممكن
القطع مع حلقات الفعل وردت الفعل